hey everyone it's Michael vaus here from
orderflows dcom and this is today's
orderflows trade analysis for Tuesday
February 14
2017 and you know it was Valentine's Day
I I wasn't able to sit in front of the
screen most of the day then it didn't
really matter cuz my my connection went
down late in the day and I lost some of
my data but you know what there were
some interesting things that I want to
talk about in the order flow but before
I get started uh go through the brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only it should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures Trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future
results the three tools actually it's
four um
used in this presentation it's the
orderflows trader software which is the
footprint chart the volto flip the volto
U-turn and the volto transition these
three indicators are orderflow based
indicators to highlight things in the
order flow so if you're looking at an
overflows Traders chart you know you can
concentrate on what's happening in the
market without having to make you know
the the the decisions you know each one
indicates something different in the
order flow it it just helps make
orderflow trade
easier for
you okay so this is a eurocurrency this
is a one minute chart and you know I
just want to point out you know
something you know orderflow often times
is about reading patterns in the market
you know it whether it's you know volume
based or whether it's Delta based you
know there are certain patterns that
repeat themselves I mean they're not
going to be exactly 100% the same every
time but you're you're looking sort for
the sort of the same framework and you
know this was a perfect example this
morning this was then the the euro
currency one minute chart and you know
just after 12:00 you can see the market
was you know it was it was working its
way down right it was working its way
down gets down in here you know just off
the low the low is uh 10571 we came down
to 72 so about a tick off the low but as
you as you see it coming down here um
you know in here it's got some smallish
Deltas then you get this last big push -
92 Delta - 45 then 12 right here you got
the bar turning up
and the next bar is positive Delta of 22
positive 42 you know this five bar
structure so to speak is you know is is
a
very I say powerful but it's a strong
it's usually a strong signal you what
you have is you you're coming down Delta
is picking up here it's very strong gets
weaker gets you know kind of neutral
here right in the middle and then it
starts growing on the way back back up
so you know it's strong less strong
neutral strong and stronger um I don't
know how else to describe it but you
know if you're looking at the these
Delta candles it it really shows out
there but if you you could I mean if you
just say you don't have these candles if
you're just reading the Delta like this
you could see it right I mean a lot of
these things become second nature to you
when you're familiar with order flow and
you know what to look for I mean you
know a lot of people come out with these
footprint charts and but you know they
don't tell you how to read it or how to
apply it in your Market they just sort
of leave it out there for you to figure
out on your own um you know that's why I
create these videos so you can watch you
know maybe you're using you know a
orderflow chart from another company you
know whether it's uh G you know that you
got from Big mics or futures.io now but
um you know or if you have you know
another another version of the footprint
chart or even if you're on Sierra charts
um you know you could you could get all
this information as well but you know
you got to learn to look for these
patterns you know I mean it's not going
to always be the sameus 92 you know it
could be minus 120 could be then Min -
60 and positive 15 you know
and 67 and 120 you know but this is what
you're looking for something like this
you know where it's getting weaker on
the way down getting stronger on the way
up and you know you could have been
looking to be buying it in here
somewhere around this 76 area 77 area
you know we just sort of go sideways
here before we start um you know moving
up here you know I mean I don't even
know where we got up to but you know it
could have got something out of this
trade my my quotes went down right
around just after 1:00 um time to go
down about 1:30 here um so some of my so
all my charts are end at that time but
you know I'm going to show you some some
other things that that I thought was
interesting today just really quick you
know this is the Delta surge which you
get you could download from the website
for free it's a free indicator okay and
it it it reads the Delta of the order
flow and again you can download it for
free on on on my website just uh go in
there sign up but if you do download it
you know just make sure you restart your
ninja Trader after you install it don't
don't send me an email saying hey here's
my machine ID you got to restart ninja
Trader but anyway this is a four range
chart and you know I I bring this up
because you know some guy downloaded
this and he said oh you know what it's
the shittiest indicator ever I know I
don't know some people are are just so
mean um he said I ran it on for range
charts and every trade was was wrong you
if you're trading a four range chart on
crude it's going to be very very fast
you know usually you know the people
that complain the most are I hate to say
it you know I don't like putting saying
nasty things about people but generally
the the the people that are unhappy with
this is you know people that are lousy
Traders I I don't I don't like to say
say it but I I think that's true because
you know people don't give things a
chance sometimes and you know they'll
say oh I ran it on this chart today and
it was just pure [__] so ever since then
I've been putting up four range charts
on on crude on E Minis and a few other
contracts and I always look at it and
you know I really don't understand what
what people think um you know again
you're training a four range chart
you're going to be very very quick
because you know it can move super fast
on a for range chart but
again you know this is a move you know
from 50 up to I'll say up to 70 but up
to to
60 you know then you get a Sell Here
comes off because buy here you know if
if you're trading a for range chart and
you're not automated somehow you know
you get a signal here by the time you
sell it it's down here so fast and the
time you get a signal to buy it's back
down you know it's you buy it up here
then boom you come back down again um
you know have you know some sort of
concept of of what type of chart you're
trading you know and and take things in
context right if if you just had a buy
down here then you get another buy up
here well you should already be long you
shouldn't be thinking oh I missed this
buy I should be getting it up here well
you had all this other chance to get in
there you know um but anyway that's my
little bit of a rant on on that uh on
that
chart um take a look at something else
I'll go over some of the indicators real
real quick I don't think it was that
good the the 100 tick chart today wasn't
very pretty um again you know my my my
internet went out that's why I got no
charts there um that's why my my charts
end at a certain
time it's kind of frustrating um anyway
that's it so 8:30 you got a little bit
of a move here not much you know before
it sort of worked its way down again
another little move here not much before
it worked its way down got to sell here
probably would have stopped you out this
buy probably would have stopped you out
um you know these buys would have
stopped you out the
sell nothing maybe close to stopping out
maybe break even the cell didn't
work this one you could have got
something out of this one maybe not you
probably would have come back up there
and stopped you out would have been nice
if the signal wasn't there and you would
have just stayed long on on that move up
there here I I don't like these rounding
patterns like that um that one didn't
work that one's a too little bit you
know further up you it's just
unfortunate that you know you got this
buy here then you got to sell here and
then makes the move um but again you can
see how my my my system went down at
that
point yeah I'm making this video even
though you know the indicators didn't
necessarily perform that well but you
know I do want you guys um you know to
see this just so you know you don't
think that OD I'm only showing you
charts on on days that you know
everything performed well this is the
mini doll this is a five range chart now
this
is this is the flip settings are 5 and
25 um it's going back to
830 is in here okay so you got these
cells didn't work out you got this cell
comes right back with the buy again this
is you know this is preash you know I
prefer to even though this trade worked
you know I'm not really talking about it
because I prefer mini da once the cash
opens not uh right ahead of
there this one you know it started
working um this is a you know if you're
into candlesticks you know this is a
very bullish Candlestick this Hammer
here um you got another one here that
didn't really work out this one did this
one didn't as far as hammers um where
else then you got this one nice buy here
no sell signals up that all um you know
up to
there I'll talk about the orderflow
charts in a in a second um just looking
for something else here where's
my this is the 987 tick charts in the
euro currency again wasn't very much
it's kind of a again you know after
10:00 it really went pretty quiet um you
know this buy didn't work you had buy
down here which you know was was in the
money for the most part but again it's
not much of a move that day um Tuesday
in the
eurocurrency what is this one I haven't
even looked at this one this is the
everything
chart 9:00 G currency was all over the
place
uh okay the hash this is the
U-turn you so it's giving you some of
these turning points here this one not
really this one yeah this one then comes
up here again you know support there
here it's just going sideways this is
the these are the
flips you know it's got this area here
this is the Hammer sign again you know
another hmer
this is the
transition this is a hammer you
know it's a nice signal the U-Turn when
when it's on a
hammer you know here
here so that's that's it for that uh
euro currency chart this one's the crude
oil um I I make sure I change my charts
this week it's almost the r
period 987 tick chart in crude um
transition settings of uh 3100 400 the
sell didn't work this buy a little bit
you know it wasn't the market wasn't
that much movement this morning you know
buy Here didn't work out a sell a
sideways this buy didn't really work out
then this buy you know worked out but it
it it was it was very quiet very quiet
um it was kind of a quiet morning I I I
know you know
after I say I know I what I mean is um I
know there there's other movements in
these markets after after my charts went
down but um you know I'm just recording
this you know after the market closed
again you know I I wasn't I wasn't uh I
was running around doing errands today
but uh so I wasn't able to monitor the
market I'm doing this this is sort of a
post game
analysis okay so bonds you know bonds
are interesting it was very quiet in the
morning um you know coming into the uh
US Open very tight range I he had like
15117 down to
1512 so about a 15 tick range so pretty
quiet and you know we had hit our we had
touched our low again at 7 you know just
after
7:30 you know traded up towards the High
um you know you got these two bars here
you know same height same he you know
the same level you both got bearish
ratios but again you know very tight
range I wouldn't be looking to take
anything and then we started coming in
9:00 you know that's when things picked
up today and you know we went into the
lows and we we got through the lows very
fast low low low low and you know even
down here we got down to 19 1501
19 um not a ratio you know it's a green
bar though uh we did bounce back
up and we kept going down um you know
here at 9007 you have a Divergence don't
really go anywhere come in make a new
low get another
Divergence you know 936 make another low
another Divergence
now you know the last couple days I've
been talking about you know in the S&P
when you've been trending you know I'm
going to talk about the S&P also later
but you know when when you're trending
you know looking for new lows you know
with
divergences the the thing I don't like
about this I mean you can do it you'll
here but what I don't like is one you
made all these lows here with no
divergences then you get this Divergence
here and you make some more lows you
know I would expect to see a few more
divergences in here it's just powering
through the lows I mean it's nice that
you get this one here this one here
um this one here if we're going to come
back in yeah I'm going to look for us to
take out the low but how much lower can
we go I mean we we've already sold off
you know quite a bit right we went from
you know before the low was you know
before 9:00 the low is you know
15102 we sold off you know
literally over a point okay and are we
still going to keep going lower we got
down to 15 14929 here and what's
interesting when you got down to this
area look at this volume 3,000 2,000
there was some very heavy volume here
you don't see this volume and you can
see it just even on the volume number
14,000 traded there where do you have
that anywhere back here you don't you
know
so just just looking at these numbers
you don't have anything like that in
here um here it is you know 32800 so
there's there's very strong trading
going on here volume wise and even in
the next bar here you know you 1, 1400
2,700 so you know there is some support
down here you know so that's a sign that
hey well maybe we've hit this low
and you know we can maybe hopefully
rally off it so what I'd be watching now
over these next few
bars you know is some signs in the Delta
you know some strong deltas and it just
kind of goes sideways in here you know
five this bar put in a lot of volume
21,000 it had a Delta of just 500 then
you get small Delta 100 100 400 is not
big you know 400 you know these two kind
of cancel then here you're get a 12200
it comes right back withus 11100 but
what's interesting is what you can read
into this even though it's got negative
Delta of minus 1100 look at this you
know why is it- 11100 and the bar is
green so the market turned up is there
was a lot of support in this bar 1500
14400 and then you know positive 600
here 1100 1100
1500 you know as as the market you know
reaches up to this point and then you
see the selling come back in again but
you know really when this bar was well
this bar here early was quite telling
you know you be looking for some signs
then when you see this bar here minus
1100 okay and the bar turns up you know
I'd I'd be really looking for it to to
to go higher and you know and it did I
mean look at this over the next half
hour it rallied from basically
15010 all the way up to you know almost
uh you know 150 25 26 27 so that was a
nice you know that was a nice move and
there was a couple things in here that
were was quite telling this was quite
telling in here this uh selling IM
balance and this volume this 1570 and
this 1410 as well as this volume down
here right off the low this 3, 2800 and
this
3,400 okay so this is the E mini three
range chart and you right ahead of the
cash we saw some selling come in we got
this stack selling in Balance you got
some nice negative Deltas here 500 2100
2,000 you know a little bit earlier 8:00
you did have this imbalance but again
and look how quiet the market is over
the next 10 minutes the market did
nothing we're still trading inside that
imbalance and you're coming up on 830
you're still sort of trading in there
again it's not the strongest sign um
again I wouldn't be looking to take any
trade like this right ahead of the cash
open if I did I'd be looking for it to
happen over the next 10 minutes not over
how many bars I'd really be looking for
a move to happen but you tend not to get
these nice moves once right when you're
trading right ahead of the cash open um
you know markets will sort of quiet down
going into the cash open and then things
will pick up again in this case they
picked up to the downside so even though
you have this imbalance
here yeah it's nice but again is it
tradable probably not what I think is
more telling and this is is something
that I've highlighted many times is when
you have these what I call opposing
imbalances here you have a stack buying
imbalance and then within that five bar
range right this is 1 2 3 four you're in
the fourth bar you have a stack selling
imbalance so you have an imbalance in
the opposite direction usually this is
very high percentage trade okay so you
go with this direction Direction and
what does the market do is it comes off
you know it makes a new low you got
another imbalance you know it's still
it's overlapping this time it's it's
right in that area and you just you know
you you rally unfortunately um you know
honestly I I would normally expect it to
sell off a bit more but in this case it
it didn't you know it was I see what the
word was it was quite
uh quite it
interesting morning know right around
this 8:30 time you know this is 8:30 831
832 in here
833 and you know you come up here all
right you got up
to this area this is the price rejector
both you know this the price rejector
here but then you got it again at these
two levels and then you start coming off
again um you know the thing with trading
around the cash
open you know right now my my trading
room is closed I haven't decided if I'm
going to reopen it or not but the thing
with the cash you know if I talk about
it every day in the trading room I don't
trade during the cash open I let it
settle down after about 5 minutes and
then I trade because I know that lots of
times you get these
reactions you know you get a move down
then you get a move up right so look at
where we're trading right before the
cash open 24 23 24 get down to 22 and
A2 and then you rally back up you know
back up to well in this case is only
25 um but you did get way up to you know
six and a six and a quarter up here so
you know it's about a fivepoint range
and then the market settles down I mean
that's when you could be looking to
trade okay now watch what you got here
you got imbal uh when you make this new
low you making a low by a tick
Divergence Divergence this time with the
ratio you do pop up a little bit then
you come up here you got a ratio bounds
low so it's a bearish
ratio come in here got another
Divergence so right now you've had 1 2 3
and what time 846
to
856 would I I'd be watching to see
what's going to happen if we're going to
take out this low I'd be probably be
looking to sell it um 9:00 a lot of
stuff happened and what did you
do you did make a new low but by two
ticks right what what can you do then
you come back up
here bearish ratio and you got this
bullish ratio right here point of
control right at the bottom again I
always say watch these bars you know the
green candle with the point of control
at the bottom or if it was a red candle
it' be on the top these are usually very
potent uh bars however at this time you
know watch how fast this Market's moving
here 9:00 boom boom boom and then you
make a new low so and this comes right
after a bearish ratio so again I'm
always hesitant to take trades where you
have a bearish number then a bullish
number right in the next bar I prefer to
get these when you know I'd be really
more interested Ed in this if this
wasn't a bearish ratio you know that's
just me um so you know had you sold here
off these diverges thinking we're going
to make a new low you know you'd still
be short I think because you'd be you
know you'd be getting short around this
32 uh 22 area it trades up to uh what is
that three and a half so want a point
and a half against you um again you know
normally I would find this to be very
bullish but it comes after a very be I
say very a bearish signal um and and I
don't like to take one right after the
other then what happens we come back
down in here uh a few minutes later make
a new low you know so again if you're
short off in here off these three
divergences you know you could still be
short this is the Delta surge given a
cell here um again it's encouraging to
get this big selling imbalance in here
1,700 and you know we come back down we
make this new low here at
99008 so you know from 2 down to to 302
and then then you bounce up from it okay
you got Al you're seeing some very nice
imbalances but again this move is very
fast this is why you got to be trailing
your stop in you should have a stop in
at the very minimum you know you should
be looking at around the 24 area because
you know what you don't want to be doing
is is getting short off off of this you
know you're short in here and thinking
ah you know I'll give it I'll give it
you know up to five or something no I
mean you shouldn't especially after
we've come up to uh 3 and a half a
couple times or once and when you got to
three and a quarter you know four is is
pretty tight if you're trailing it you
know maybe could as we come into new
lows you could lower it a bit down you
know
to you know to three and then you know
down through it maybe down to break even
but again that would be a stretch I
think I'd probably have stayed at around
the three area or even four um and it
sto me out so you know yeah you did have
a trade that was in your favor a little
bit but you it didn't really give you
much much in it you know you're getting
short
around um you know 22 22 and A2 and and
how where' it go it only went down to 20
and A2 before turning around when I see
big imbalances like this going against
me usually as a sign for me to get out
and you can see it just moved very
fast then you know we went up up got up
to this area came off a bit went
sideways um you know we did later make a
new low but again I'm not I'm not
advocating you know taking heat all the
way up to you know to
25 and then hoping it's going to come
back down honestly you know when when it
makes this move here I'm looking I'm
like that's it man this this low is
going to hold I'm not necessarily
looking for it to sort of sput around
and then come down and make new lows
down in here definitely not at all so
you know we got down the 19 and 3/4 okay
so you got a Divergence there no ratio
you got this nice imbalance I love
taking imbalances off lows this next bar
we pull back into the
imbalance before continuing back up and
you know we sort of go up a little bit
um we get up to 24 you know just then
just go
sideways come back down hit the low
again another Divergence close to a
ratio that I would find um to be bullish
you know I use uh 7 or I think 69 um
this is 74 so it's close close but no
cigar um I'm
just
whoops I was trying to show you my
setting there and I think I just screwed
it
up there we go
[Music]
um so that setting right is this one 69
so you can see here it's 74 so it's
close you there's not much difference
between 74 and 699 but anyway um it
doesn't meet the qualification but then
here you got another couple of things
one you have the Divergence two you have
the ratio afterwards three you have a
three in a row ratio ratio ratio show
four you have a stacked imbalance so you
got a lot of bullish bullish signs off
this low really um you have the
Divergence with the ratio then you have
the three ratios in a row then you
have a stacked imbalance it's close to a
Delta surge here
um you see the rising Delta 300 500
2,000 you know which is also nice to see
an increase in Delta like
that and what do you do you went from
the low at 19 and
3/4 and that was it I think that was
pretty much the low for the day if I if
I remember right and then you come up
here to the highs I like to see when you
break through the highs I like to see
imbalances you got one two there that's
nice get up here you got a Divergence
with a ratio you come off in the next
bar a little bit by a couple ticks and
then you just come right back up this is
the Delta surge so you know had you been
short off of this um I'm not sure I
would have gotten short off of this I
mean we literally just made a move from
our low up to our high and then you get
a Divergence with the ratio be careful
um again you know take things in context
it's not like we had just been sort of
trading around the highs you know for
the last few hours we literally just
went from this from the low down
here you know this is at uh 10:08 right
you know 108 up to the these highs up
here you know
in you know in an hour hour and a half
less than so you know it's not like we
just sort of been Meandering around you
know where the low Was Made 4 hours ago
it literally was a straight oh not a
straight move but it was a move from the
low right up to the
high and then you get this again you
know I'm always looking for signs when
you take out the high looking for signs
that were going to keep going higher
here you got these
imbalances 780 900 even here
300 then here this is nice to see you
got the Delta surge so you got Delta
increasing right at the high so you know
buyers are coming
in and you you just keep making new
highs you know you go from the 29 area
up all the way up you know up up here
you got another another one of these
divergences
with a ratio ratio on the next one I
would have expected more out of it but
what happens you come right back here
with a bullish ratio and look at this
volume 4,000 2,000 even here 300 uh
sorry 3,000 so you know you're putting
in some lot of volume in here you know
this is potentially a support level and
you can see you come back down here
another 2,000 trade another 3,000 trade
and you just keep going
up another Delta surge here you keep you
take out this High boom boom
you got diver uh imbalance imbalance
imbalance and you know that's all I got
on my charge for the day
unfortunately
so yeah let me see if there's any one
other chart I could show you guys just
really quick
um show you
well this is the the U-turn U-turn
wasn't that great this morning um you
know basically since the cash open
that's a little early I mean that's
before
7 still that was nice got a nice buy
here right ahead of the cash that worked
out this one not really it's a three-
range chart this one took a little bit
heat before it went up this one started
working then failed that one failed and
then you know here late in the day um
I'm trying to think
uh March IM min's uh
sleet
[Music]
um yeah anyway um you know
electronically overnight right now
they're let's R midnight actually I'm
recording
this I'm not saying you would hold it
until now but um yeah we did close the
the session around up here at 37 again I
don't know
what what transpired in here um you know
after this but I I do know we settled up
in here so you know maybe you could have
got something out of it I I don't know I
I don't know I won't know till I take a
look at the the these charts in here um
a Dax chart I just wanted to take a look
at if I can find it
but I mean you know I mean again you
know these indicators they're designed
to help help help you read the order
flow
um you know
it's once you're comfortable with order
flow you you really
don't don't need them um I don't say
don't need them but you know
it's a lot of the stuff becomes secondly
obviously if you're looking at a bar
chart you're going to need it if you're
looking at order flows chart um
yeah you can sort of pick up some of
these things by yourself you know but
again it comes with it comes with um
experience right you got to have you
know the experience of of looking at
looking at the
charts and and know what and know what
you're looking
for um just give me one sec
I thought I had a Dax chart um I'm just
trying to find it where are
you yeah decks you know I mean people
always say you know hey what can I use
orderflow with um you know you could use
it with anything I'm not sure if I
showed this already this is the mini Dow
10 range charge so this is the flip
right and you know basically there was
just the one signal here here
10:00 so basically it move from the 375
area up up up that's it gives tells you
to buy and that that was it um people
ask how many charts do I look at I look
at look at markets is uh mini da e-
minis
bonds and I do keep crude and and and
and Euro currency but then you know once
I I have these charts up I I got
different time ranges not a lot but like
mini da I look at a 100 tick chart 10
range and uh five range for EUR currency
I look at 1 minute I look
at uh it was at eight range and you know
987 tick charts I look on on all the
Commodities that I that I watch as
well you know e- minis I look at you
know three range I look at 10 range
depending on how fast the Market's
moving if it's moving fast I I'll stick
to a 10 range if it's moving slow I'll
go with uh you know a
shorter a shorter
duration um but anyway you know I'll end
this recording for now it's kind a bit
longer than I expected I I can't find my
Dax chart that I wanted to show you um
actually forgot I remember I was looking
at it earlier but I I can't remember
which which thing I wanted to talk about
but anyway um you know thanks for
watching this if if you want to know
more about orderflow or watch my
previous videos definitely subscribe to
my YouTube channel I've got a webinar
coming out in a couple weeks
that you know I'll be sending out
information on but um you know to learn
more about orderflow visit my website
orderflow
.c and thanks and I hope to see you on
the inside